butt wird sind sagen dann hast du wieder
ohne dich stress an der backe
das klappt jetzt willkommen beim neuen
video
ja es gab ja letzten samstag von mir
probleme eines singles und das ist
ziemlich gut bei euch angekommen ich
habe gefragt ob ich auch mal vorteile
von dem single haben wollt und deswegen
gibt es heute wirklich vorteile
jede singles ich wünsche euch viel spaß
falls euch gefällt abonniere nicht
vergessen und ich würde sagen wir fangen
wir immer ganz schön dich mit punkt eins
an und zwar ist es einfach so wenn man
single ist wenn man abends weggehen man
muss nicht immer dieses verfickte
gefühle haben ob man irgendetwas falsch
wird oder ob man wegen irgendwas zu
schlechtes gewissen muss oder ob man
irgendwas gemacht hat wo die freundin
hat denken könnte das war doch versteht
ihr das was was man eigentlich gar nicht
schmeckt also man kann einfach gehen und
machen was man will fertig zweiter punkt
ist wenn man sich so ins bett geht hat
mit jogginghose oben gar nix oder suchen
dich dann ist das scheißegal eigentlich
nett wenn ihr freund saß dann musste
immer hier auch ich muss mir noch fertig
machen ihr wisst ihr förder und da und
wenn du halt keine freundin hast dann
kannst du sagen
heute mache ich gar nichts kennt ihr das
bestimmt ihr kennt das ja ihr könnt das
was auch sehr befreit ist sag ich mal
und sehr zeitsparend
du musst dich immer auf dein handy
gucken und irgendwelche videos die
blödsinn oder irgendwelche fotos die
vielleicht etwas blöd sind bzw wo du
halt dann streit endspurts streit
entstehen könnte oder irgendwelche leute
ganz einfach drauf lassen das scheißegal
weg ein
und das ist auch sehr gut was mir auch
so aufgefallen ist man musste ich
irgendwelche wird das ist ja bei frauen
oder mädchen immer so jedes datum was
ihnen eine besondere bedeutung hat muss
man automatisch auch im kopf bald aber
wenn du als single bis dann brauchst du
gar nicht diese 20.000 verschiedenen
daten im kopf haben weil sie keinen job
ihr kennt das doch bestimmt art wie du
erinnerst dich nicht mehr an dem tag an
dem wir das erste mal zusammen spazieren
gegangen sei irgendwie sogar teilen ja
nächster punkt ich weiß gar nicht wo
schon sind auf jeden fall
man kann richtig so du kannst mit jedem
halt was machen auf dem rad bock hast
und
so halten wenn deine freunde es dann
könnte es sein dass die freundin den und
den ich mag und so was halt meldung
musste sagen tut mir leid ich kann nicht
weil ich kopfschmerzen
ja wenn ich versuche mein zimmer sieht
eigentlich aufgeräumt aus aber man
könnte oder man es ist nicht mehr so
wichtig dass dein zimmer auf brand ist
dass du immer halt deine sachen unters
bett schweiß oder im schrank ein ort ist
sondern du kannst es einfach so lassen
dass interessierte keil und von daher
ist auch so ein typisches vorteil denke
ich mal ja wat auch noch sehr cool ist
du musst halt nicht wegen jeder
kleinigkeit eifersüchtig sein oder du
wirst auch generell nicht so von dem
anderen mit 1 versöhnlichkeit kontron
kontron konfrontiert wenn man halt
irgendwas vielleicht ein bisschen falsch
gemacht hat und daraus auch schon direkt
wieder der nächste punkt und man ist
auch generell eigentlich so viel
relaxter also gar nicht mehr so
gestresst weil halt nicht diese
situation passieren wo aus einer
kleinigkeit ein streit wird man sagt ja
immer aus einer mücke ein elefant oder
so ähnlich des weiteren gibt es auch
noch diese situation da hat man einfach
mal an dem tag keinen bock auf seine
freunde oder sein freuen ich weiß nicht
ob du mädchen und jungen bis der welt
zuschaut
aber da gibts sei dieser tage war da
muss man sagt man kann ja nicht sagen
ich habe keinen bock auf dich da kann
man ja nicht machen aber wenn man halt
wenn man ernsthaft so kein bock hat kann
es halt nichts machen wenn der andere
will was willst denn sagen dann hast du
wieder ohne die strabag ist und was
eigentlich auch noch sehr sehr positiv
ist diese ganze zeit die in diesem
beziehungskrach geht kannst du viel mehr
in ein hobby investieren zum beispiel
ich jetzt ich hab so viel zeit was heißt
viel zeit ich jetzt jeden tag von 8 bis
16 uhr in der schule beziehungsweise
auch mal bis halb sechs warum auch immer
aber kann sich hier sagen ach ich geh
jetzt bisschen hierfür youtube maria
ward oder ich weiß nicht macht
jedenfalls anderes was mir spaß macht so
ich habe zum beispiel zwei videos sie
bekommen weil ich halt viel mehr zeit
hat ja heute das waren jetzt erstmal ein
paar vorteile ich hab noch mehr auf
lager also wenn ihr
auch im zweiten teil davon sehen lassen
doch nach oben dann weiß ich bescheid
jetzt noch mal schön instagram
eingeblendet check das auf jeden fall ab
da kommen die meisten bilder oder auch
nicht auf doch noch bisschen zum ab und
zu machen und an sonst würd ich sagen
ich fahre habe ich eben schon gesagt
egal abonniert wenn ihr bock haben und
hier auf der linken seite geht es weiter
mit dem anderen teil hiervon
beziehungsweise mit dem gegenstück
hiervon und zwar dass probleme eines
singles die auf der anderen seite mit
mein base video das war habe ich paar
fragen an bord von euch und ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen samstag schönes
wochenende und hort relativ wir sehen
uns mittwoch